hallo zusammen
schön dass ihr wieder dabei seit heute
habe ich ein einfaches und schnelles
rezept für euch den coffee cream cheese
cake für den cheesecake benötigen wir
700 gramm doppel ram frisch lisa ein
teelöffel vanille extrakt den saft einer
halben zitrone 80 gramm schmandt fünf
eier und 200 gramm zucker als erstes
gebe ich den vanille extrakt und den
zitronensaft zum frischkäse und verrührt
das mit einem schneebesen
dann gebe ich den schmand dazu und auch
den zucker und zum schluss gebe ich
nacheinander die eier hinein
ich habe mir meinen ba kam auf 24
zentimeter eingestellt und dem mit
backpapier eingeschlagen das packe ich
jetzt bei 170 grad ober und unterhitze
für ca 50 minuten
während mein käsekuchen gerade komplett
abkühlt berate ich schon mal die ganache
vor dafür brauche ich 300 milliliter
heiß auf gekochte sahne und eine tafel
also 200 gramm von der café sahne
schokolade das ist einmal die hier die
findet in jedem supermarkt
ich lasse die schokolade jetzt erst mal
fünf minuten lange schmelzen und
anschließend werde ich das ganze
verrühren
die ghanas stuft über mir jetzt drei bis
vier stunden lang abkühlen
ich habe sie auch zwischendurch in den
kühlschrank getan und jetzt schlage ich
sie einmal auf mit dem mixer und ich
muss sagen die schmeckt wirklich sehr
mutig cremig und total nach kaffee jetzt
verteile ich die creme auf meinem
käsekuchen
dafür habe ich mit meinen löffel
genommen und mit der rückseite das ganze
so ein bisschen unstrukturiert verteilt
weil ich dann einfach das schöne
aussagen
die deko ist jetzt völlig euch
überlassen
ich hab ihr handelsübliche karamellsoße
finde einfach dass das super harmoniert
mit dem kaffeegeschmack das gebe ich
jetzt darüber und anschließend verteile
ich noch mini kekse auf dem kuchen
diese torte ist wirklich sehr cremig
sehr lecker und der amerikanische
schießt ist ja generell schon cremig an
sich und dann noch mit der cafe creme
oben drauf also es ist wirklich ein
traum ich empfehle auf jeden fall nach
zu machen
falls euch dieses video gefallen hat und
die gerne mehr davon sehen möchtet dann
dürft ihr mich gerne kostenlos
abonnieren bis zum nächsten mal auf die
gis kitchen